alright so i am playing as jerk dong
face a name given to me because I've had
the great life misfortune to know Sean
McGinnis Tom can you explain to us how
you got your name and whatever problems
what your name is my name is dr. nasty
fingers yeah how do I that unfortunately
it's just true he's got real nasty
fingers and the doctor and he's a doctor
and he wasn't got through med school
yeah I don't have many patients anymore
no Justin how about you I'm a little
sassy good my my name my given name was
little Sebastian but i changed it after
i spent some time on the streets yeah
and getting Sebastian is not a good name
that will give you street cred unless
you're on the streets of Pawnee Indiana
Shawn hey how are you known in this game
I'm slick gelatin because Tom mcshay
told me that my name should be slick
gelatin oh and we're off let's go click
the way for Shawn i'm doing a coyote
ugly right now all these health so many
apples so why are we killing bats
because a bats are attacking us Tom it's
self-defense yeah oh yeah but we're also
in their home well we want to get true
their home is where treasure is Tom yeah
we're pursuing every story get funded
how do you get I want to get this gold I
want to get the gold first he's a race
for gold I line it I'm rich alright so
are these little sassy procedurally
generated or oh yes I believe they are
how are they generated procedurally
procedurally if you touch the fire does
it hurt I don't know if so then oh yeah
run in the water am I on fire on we go a
little sassy little sassy we need to
build a human totem pole a little but
not to be confused with a human
centipede that is a different thing also
change the silence and opposition when
they so the mouth to the button yeah
watch out for that wizard that wizard is
super bad we don't wanna fight that
wizard I'm pretty sure you don't want to
fight that wizard pretty please don't
hit that wizard k talking pretty sure
it's not a thing you want to talk to or
even like be near stop throwing goblin
hats around so I want that nice helmet
i'ma get it don't we give the three the
office yeah I got a plus for you wanna
hit the wizard now we're gonna die look
at my sick ass night helmet should we oh
it's bad it's like idiots I didn't oh no
I don't think anyone made contact with
him go out the door on door now we're in
automated door i'm in this door on the
far right for all the different doors I
don't know where you're at I got I'm
surrounded by bat [ __ ] tomato Wow wait
are we good cuz I'm gonna have to pass
are coming again no no no no no no we're
going I'm in all right you guys always
in the far right I'm gonna left why did
you guys attack the wizard mad and
nobody attack i was eating apples
someone's dead I died hold on I got a
slug some apples real quick even get
much help than I did you get five pound
rowing apples oh look at all these coins
we going oh [ __ ] I think that was all
night so the right go to the right go
all right go all right go all right go
to the right I'm not on the right I'm
gonna watch right this way for me that's
the disappeared
I'll kill him I don't even knew [ __ ] all
the events are at disappear you shoved
me out of the door you're the worst why
did you do that oh because sometimes we
have to write write write write write
this fool our logos are the grandpa
sorry guys we have some pretty sick ass
Tom guys for everything that's gone
wrong our hat situation is pretty much
on point on point yeah we're pretty much
rocking it with the hat situation they
get that Apple you are bitten little
sassy way we have to go back and look at
a horrible carnage go back I'm still
gonna be there my stuff is still there
get all my stuff just go get that stuff
I need you to get my stuff oh I just got
destroyed yeah I did I like the thing
and then it came back and crushed me
don't hit the switches how amazing yes
my oh you guys can borrow my Cthulhu
mask if I give it to me when I come back
to life you have 22 apples what eats an
apple he just daughter to have them all
I just basically grabbed all Sean's
apple right there's some dude will sassy
no save them all for me those are my
apples all right yeah that's true Sean
don't use all my [ __ ] come on oh listen
I'll save you Apple you died oh this you
should potion is sickly green potion
look what I have that's all my good
stuff oh my gosh kidding Sean I was
hoarding hey you guys should hit this
switch on the right and then stand here
so that haha Oh like that I'm gonna
throw these cats down and then kill them
they're both the same you can't do wheel
is our murderer and cat
can you go I died haha we got
achievement called pedo pedo of dead wow
you guys both got murdered because of
Sean's a terrible cat slaughter Oh did
anybody let's go back down and grass
back I'll get their stuff yeah go back
down grab stuff the army avenged oh and
go do it do it no I want to kill know
it's a plants vs zombie if I gonna do it
all over again I go get my stuff go get
my stuff trying to get some so go get my
stuff I'll be dead I'm fine being dead
no otherwise you're gonna forget where
my stuff is listen I uh get it you love
your Cthulhu hat I love it more hammer
that thing is incredible I'll look at
him all right all right now you go down
and get it cuz you have [ __ ] meulen
error oh go get my stuff it's right here
it's just right here great now kill
everything oh they can't come in here
kill those spirits with Neil near I
don't know if they're oh you guys know
that was actually not a those offenses
all right it's all you jerk dong face
well well well look Dirk dog face don't
get Justin stuff yeah go get Janice oh
yeah that's a we're gonna tell you y
especially get that hammer cuz that
thing is baller as hell oh I can push it
towards you know what I heard an
exasperated sigh I didn't kill a kid
let's go Tom what kind of wisdom do you
have to offer after your first go here
legend of Dungeon Tom aka dr. nasty
fingers so just if someone has like
stitches and there's an open butt hole
somewhere don't go anywhere near it why
do we even let your screams sorry if
someone has an open bouncing oh [ __ ]
friggin idiot oh yeah we were gone south
already Thomas already ate health
because he's picking up bar fight with
mint wandering me oh my
God what he doesn't want looking
passenger these fingers on the pole all
right well I gotta fight all the
skeletons BAM eat it all you skeleton
who's pushing all of those knees oh wow
thanks I get all that stuff thanks Sean
mush oven we all heard that my bad what
is it on East and powering this oh no
all right good roller city yes topical
we're just gonna do massive quotes until
you whoa I got a plasma ball hell that
on your head writing plasma ball had a
producing I should put it on my head yes
yes oh wow oh I'm so jealous that's
pretty cool ojeleye having money
airstrips on your bunny ears all right
here which one of you is Chris I'm the
one with the lantern I'm gonna throw
them at you to make sure nobody steals
them because I'm gonna be honest these
hats are pretty hot commodity right now
okay fake them all out don't worry come
on going deep I'm going deep yeah
basically sports Ryan dad hook up who's
got the funny years now for you it's me
sucka fingers crossed don't go to the
okay idealistic like it nope you learned
it badly go I'm going everyone is
pressing out now right I am alright well
I'm trying oh come on ghost I want it
let me get a nice one they're gonna
disappear okay all right no don't push
us out I want to take a shuttle I think
I tell them I kill them so many things
you can eat Wow hey nice work I know
that's what I did it Tom good job calm
and proud of you you're brave adventurer
watch out oh you're on I locked it
you're gonna make charged enough
protection just shake it off stop drop
and roll all right stop walking on
things makes the fire happen oh damn it
why did you do that haha no mental over
there it's lava it's fire and lava but i
will get your stuff for you you want to
carry around all those dumb hats yeah
you didn't really have a lot i'ma go
come on come on it's on 50 rome fire how
do i fire don't go in with us you're on
fire little sassy of 90 good riddance I
need worse to you guys I didn't set
myself on fire I'm gonna die hey
everyone fired you do don't run near
each other oh that's gonna pass a fire
back in for all right down down oh you
guys don't want to tangle of blowing
skull wizard Tom does I'm gonna die I
like Tom I'm gonna get smoked go fight
on come on go fight him I got right away
y'all go go gonna kill whoa not yet men
look it's all gonna just don't anger him
guys don't worry all right [ __ ] no I'm
gonna middle not Shanna sir richard's
have other motives other than mover I
died he up this minute are you like all
my hats and money's now just go out the
door little don't go to the middle door
regard middle door oh what's one's on
you bunny I would survive hahahaha I
don't know all that one health this will
go well were you just hiding in a door I
went through the middle door its work
how you can dive
horrible wizard and although all the
ghosts are on fire not me quicks that's
fine that muddy brown potion get the
potion get the potion where's push-up
slug it if it's the muddy brown one now
kill that wizard so I'm behind tell on
his Souls yeah go after him this dome on
so we don't worry just [ __ ] go to
town on that guy yeah you are going to
tell on him don't push him into some
lava maybe you're definitely justice Oh
goes push him go sucking you in person
give me those solos nicely dead uh Tom
are you on fire also like me oh you guys
just felt it alone photo torment all
right now the hell this guy so I can get
his soul oh yeah it did oh you found a
new thing advocates me I'll kill that
demon raccoon ah wow you're feeling
strong we made it pretty far hey way to
be virtuous by a Minotaur where's my
mummy yeah shoot up buying him and burn
to death I see go way to go all right
type in multiple players on your legend
of dungeon seed and see if you get beat
that modestly not terrible scores that
we all scored yeah ah legend of dungeon
is available on Steam right now for 999
so you can pick it up ah fun local co-op
as you can see Victoria how much bitcoin
is that I don't know I am NOT an
economist somebody no coin dogecoin
hello dodo eggs are there we're ending
the stream like a medium cuz I had about
all I could take my wonderful coworkers
thank you guys for tuning into multiple
players today much appreciated on next
week multiple players is gonna be
celebrating video game history month as
will be much of GameSpot and we're
kicking it off with some panic on funkin
Tron it's oh oh please join us then and
also tune in tomorrow because sean is
gonna do a live stream thing 11am sure
on yes I am again you playing on ah
we're gonna have some fun with metal
gear solid ground zeroes yes ya got that
in the lobby tomorrow so be sure to come
on back thanks for watching folks see
you tomorrow